- These are probably the
most popular categories.
We got "Lesbian",
"Babysitter", "Big Dick”…
- What are are you craving?
- Please don't say it like that.
(dramatic music)
- You've never watched porn by yourself?
- No, no no.
- We have never watched porn together.
- That's about to change
though, it would seem.
- I'm gonna do that coy thing
where I pretend like I
don't know any websites.
- No, he does.
- Oh, yeah, ok.
- He knows.
- You have a particular one? I don't.
- What?
- (laughs)
- Yeah, I do.
- Oh, pop-up.
- So immediately, the
first thing you notice
with these sites is the
advertisements are certainly enabled
right when you go to the home page.
- There's an advertisement
for "Juicy Boys".
- I was gonna pick one, but it said teen
and I don't wanna support that.
- Oh, goodness.
- Oh.
- He's not gay.
- But they're not really teenagers.
- Not even close.
- Do I wanna know what "gaping" is?
I think I know what it is.
- We've got "Indian", "Anti-sex".
- Lets just watch this then.
- Oh! No! I hate fisting!
- Oh I do like the body shop ones.
- And they're in the body
shop and they're like
"Hey, you need an oil
change, wanna do it?"
- This is cute. It's like a little story.
- I don't think anything
about this is cute.
- And the bathing suit is coming off.
- They're auditioning for
a job, but there is no job.
- Oh! (laughs)
- Wow! You really picked one
- (laughs)
- So now, this is the audition.
- He fucks her in the audition!
- Like if you were auditioning for a movie
you'd say the lines, right?
- Cayanna Lee gets fucked by two cocks.
- You think those are fake?
- Those are definitely fake.
- Oh, there's number one and number two.
- They're very different sizes.
- Very different shapes.
- It's rather long.
- Not gonna, you know...
- Babe, you're fine.
- Ok, yeah.
- You know what would be funny.
If she just like backed up
and like slammed the
dicks together. (laughs)
- I just wanna fast forward
to getting the big one.
- Always wants to fast forward.
- See, this is where most guys would skip.
- Ah, wow! Baby!
- (laughs)
- She's pretending to be very into it.
- You think she's pretending?
- (laughs) Yes.
- Oh! It's a close up!
- Look, look, look!
- No, I don't want to.
- She's being very dramatic.
- Yeah.
- See, she's making so much noise.
- This position feels and
looks impossible to me.
- Oh she just slapped his dick!
She slapped it!
- Alright, this amazing
orgy is 56 minutes.
- There's gotta be
something in that for you.
- (laughs) Oh my god.
- Guys love to come on
girls' faces, I guess.
- I don't know. It's not like I go around
just jizzing on people's faces.
- Maybe you had some insight
into the male psyche.
- Don't they do party games first?
Like why aren't they... oh here we go.
- This is the party game. Ok, here we go.
- That's, ok, so that's what DP means.
- I'm sure there are
realistic porns out there.
But like 90% of them...
- What we just watched, no.
- (laughs) No. (laughs) Not even close.
- Like the girls always sound
like they're having orgasms.
And what the guy's doing
is not really causing an orgasm.
And I think that's almost the worst part.
- I mean that's why they make porn,
'cause it's stuff that
you don't get in your everyday life.
- That's the fantasies that you...
- Yeah, exactly.
- It's pretty demoralizing sometimes.
- 'Cause, it's like, what
am I doing wrong here?
- (laughs)
- Yeah, just watching it together.
- Is a little more awkward than normal.
- (laughs) Now he knows that I'm
- (laughs)
- (laughs) Just average.
- Like who wants to see a close up
of the insertion?
- Liquids that are like coming out of
places that they shouldn't be. (laughs)
- So would you say that you at least
have an appreciation,
or a respect for what they do?
- 100% Oh yeah, I think that it's great
that porn exists.
- I don't think I could ever
sit down and seriously be like
"Hey lets do this together as foreplay."
That just is
- I'd rather
- I feel like I don’t want or need...
- I don't know, I'd just
be with you for foreplay.
- Right. (laughs) This is getting weird.
(whimsical music)
- Oh the couch is all,
The couch is (bleep)